you've exposed yourself as well yes yeah
we don't have a picture side become
better but actually if you could find
the women involved in this story how
brilliant but we haven't but go resist
me working in that very brother sort of
grubby cafe being a this greasy teenager
and wearing my very tight tight black
jeans feeling coming to have their
entering the bakery early in the morning
from a late night out and having just
learned how to make cappuccinos captions
are just arrived in England been around
for a while and so I used to make them
terribly big and frothy not how you
meant to make them they look sort of
repulsive and undrinkable but at the
time and I put them Burt ooh lovely
lovely ladies coming into the cafe and
and I think I was holding I just learned
how to hold the two cappuccinos in one
hand which I was very impressed by and
then I had some hot revolting greasy
crock something-or-other what's it
called a croque monsieur proposition and
the other and I did I had these terrible
old jeans on which had a big hole in the
fence and I was placing them down
shaking and sort of feeling rather
sweaty and anxious anyway they're by my
thing just fell out and just dangled and
rested on the edge and I saw where of it
I miss
exact expression
it was just neatly resting on the end
and I folded in and it was all it was a
horrible woman you are giving your [__]
sellout finale Danville rested on the
air there's nothing I could do cuz I was
holding
oh they heard they were repulsed by his
bed it was a patisserie of hava hi
Ausmus did you
did you release her to go snooze I had I
just backed off enjoying it was really
pathetic they're not very good they
didn't look I know I don't know what it
did yeah well you mentioned it earlier
but that was because I saw it I didn't
see it out of them
why don't I think enough people she gave
me some very good advice
I mentioned my penis he's beautiful II
know
I loved you I loved it
/ rappelled is rappelled not repulse I
left you alone and makeup for 10 minutes
I was very impressed you noticed it all
together the funny thing is when you're
gay as I am and you never see a [__]
from you know Martin Mass to to
Christmas um you know very aware of them
very short
early X yeah hey yeah there's a
matchmake and it got me looking forward
to it like a Saturday uh-huh tonight
sprite got my ray-bans honor my eyes
wide shut
I just think it walk heel heel to toe
heel to toe that's like you to talk I
didn't do it toda like more to